let's get more now on what's happening
in Ukraine I'm joined by retired Air by
Marshall Sean Bell Sean welcome back
um let's start by what's been happening
overnight in Ukraine talk us through it
well the big story is these Russia's
launching about over 50 of these cruise
missiles at Targets all over Ukraine
Ukraine has claimed that they've shot
down about 44 of them but the fact is
that several do appear to have got
through Russia seems to be targeting
critical infrastructure so power and
water across the country there's been a
couple of attacks in Kiev car keys have
been under attack zap breacher but to be
honest they've been taxed all over the
country these are not military targets
let's be quite clear none of these
targets help further Putin's military
Ambitions in the region almost certainly
more done to terrorize the local
population particularly with winter fast
approaching the irony of the story is
that quite the opposite effects likely
to happen it will simply Galvanize the
ukrainian's effort to repel the Russian
Invaders
um interesting look this bombing seems
to have been done by the Russian
strategic bomber Force we haven't heard
much about them at all um most of the
Russian Air Force has been involved has
been the small Fighters they're
relatively small and fast but they don't
have much range and they can't carry big
payloads and Ukraine has been really
dangerous airspace it's really well
defended by the ukrainians the advantage
of the big bombers and they can carry
much bigger missiles and they can
therefore launch them from hundreds of
miles away from their target and looks
likely they've been Russians have been
launching these from Russia from the sea
of azov down here and also from Belarus
up to the north yeah speaking of Belarus
there's been a lot of talk hasn't there
throughout the course of this war of
Russia's close Ally being dragged into
the conflict and that talk has been
renewed over the weekend what's the
latest there yeah president kashenko is
heavily reliant on Putin for his for
power it's literally earlier on this
year Putin helped keep him in power
where there was lots of unrest Russia
has launched missile attacks on Ukraine
from Belarus soil but so far the
Belarusian military has not got directly
involved itself however we have heard
the story that kalyanovsky regiment
hundreds of
um Belarusian soldiers are active in
Ukraine but interestingly they're
fighting for Ukraine against Russia the
logic being that obviously lukashenko is
that not a very popular leader in
Belarus if Putin was to fail with
adventures in Ukraine Putin leaves
suddenly lukashenko is is desperately
short of of support it's also evident 90
of the Belarusian military has said we
will not fight against Ukraine in that
war so it looks likely at the moment
belarusi is going to Simply support
Russia and of late of notes they gave up
90 of their main battle tanks Belarus
does not have a lot of these to give to
plug gaps in the Russian military and
that just shows lamentable states of
Russians military machine at the moment
the foreign secretary James cleverley is
standing at the moment in the House of
Commons giving a statement on Ukraine
one of the lines that's come out of that
is uh the foreign secretary urging
Russia to stop impeding grain exports
because Russia pulled out of a big grain
deal over the weekend talk to us about
the significance of this and how it
feeds into the the global impact of this
war well the British government as with
International governments and NATO have
all condemned Russia for weaponizing
food I mean a simple answer is by
reducing the supply of grain to the
world you increase the price of it and
those who can least afford it the ones
that suffer the most at face value
President Putin is doing this as a
degree of Retribution again for the
Drone attacks down the Black Sea Fleet
but I think that's a bit too simplistic
I think you have to look more
strategically at the problem the war is
not going well let's be blunt for Putin
in in the Ukraine and one of the key
reasons for that is the Western Alliance
of countries that are providing
high-tech weapons for Ukraine if there
was anything that Peter could do to
disrupt that he'd be all over it if
Putin can seize the remaining part of
the Don bass which he doesn't currently
own he could turn around to his domestic
audience at home claim success for his
special military operation and use the
winter period where the normally a pause
in fighting to start negotiations now if
that was his plan food would be a really
powerful bargaining chip and the
negotiating table particularly if the
West was involved in those conversations
okay Sean thank you